well john cena is in fast nine and i
know i'm excited so how did he end up in
the movie
okay so obviously i'm multicultural
you could have cast anybody to be my
brother
anybody
you could have cast anybody in the world
to be my brother yeah
and it would be okay um
for two months before i went to filming
i created a shrine
where i could do all the combat training
all the stunts
and i had the charger there to simulate
the garage
yeah to get into this down state of mind
the idea of the brother worked great on
paper
but when the time came to cast it
anxiety who could you cast
to be dom's brother and and 20 years
into the game
and the audience knows our mythology so
much who could you cast
yeah to play people are so invested yeah
yeah and he comes into the shrine one
morning
and i had this strange feeling
and if you look back on my instagram
you'll see the post
because i thanked pablo as i had the
strange feeling
that paul walker had sent him oh you
just had a feeling from
for oh that's magical very magical
you